hey it's Justine and right now in a
facility hall in New York and we're
heading into an event for Sony's 360
reality audio they announced this this
year at CES I didn't get a chance to
demo it there but today I'm gonna
finally get to check it out they also
announced the new artist hopping on
forward this new 360 reality platform at
Mark Ronson Pharrell and they're also
announcing some older artists like the
rajole and Bob Dylan this is really
exciting because taking these songs that
we all know and love and turning them
into this 360 reality experience it's
pretty cool let's go ahead into the
event and see if we can learn a little
bit more about the 360 reality audio
let's go
a huge thank you to Sony 360 reality
audio for sponsoring the
so the way that people here is different
and what's really cool about 260 audio
is it's trying to take that real life
experience and mimic that into a
headphone experience for all users the
way that 360 reality audio works is
using object audio technologies Sony
software maps sound sources it's like
instruments in a 360 space that's able
to determine distance and sound
reflection of instruments and vocals but
what's really cool is it can personally
optimize the sound for the shape of your
ear look I can't even make this up the
app actually scans the shape of your ear
so that it can personally optimize that
sound for the shape of your ear like
this is insane this is crazy
bop head over and test it out now so
let's go check it out this is our
superior one phone and basically you can
do this on any Android or Apple device
and basically you want to go into their
headphones app this is the app that's
going to help to customize it so right
now we're gonna get my ears calibrated
this is super exciting sorry I'm next
hitting next it's gonna so you're gonna
go straight over keep your hands on the
bottom
take a step back for me and it gets it
in so I'm gonna pour you back a little
bit my ears are now officially optimized
see me the first time that I'm trying
this out I saw this yes but I didn't get
a chance to demo it so I'm so excited
let me try it
you want to get her face while she's
bugging out okay
it's kind of hard for you guys to hear
what I'm hearing actually it's
completely impossible for you to hear it
so while she's jamming I can tell you
yeah those are I was but you aren't
going to hear me
so she was listening to and the real big
thing about 360 is it takes you into
almost another dimension it's object
based 360-degree listening so it's not
like left right audio boring which just
sounds loud but you're hearing
instruments all around your head so you
hear something above you behind you and
it really recreates you being on stage
with everybody around you is pretty cool
we appreciate it
this sounds so good so on stage mark
ronson and you haven't performed this
song I'd never heard the song before so
now having seen it live and now here in
360 audio
so freaking awesome am i yelling
so stereo audio is just the left in the
right 360 expands that soundscape to a
dynamic environment you can match up to
128 locations in a circular environment
so not only is this a really great new
format for us as listeners or for
creators and performers this is really
awesome so I'm gonna chat with Mike who
is actually on stage with Mark Ronson
about how this actually works as a
producer hey I'm Mike Piazza teenie I'm
a mastering engineer at battery Studios
which is Sony's in-house music
production studio we've been doing a lot
of work with the summer 2016 reality
audio we have a new program that we're
giving to producers that lets us create
this these kind of mix it's a it's an
object based program where you could
take the individual elements of the mix
like the drums bass vocals guitars and
put them wherever you want and 360
degrees or
well that was perfect I didn't have to
ask a question that was incredible so
this is the Amazon echo studio this is
one of the first smart speakers to
actually take advantage of the 360
reality audio definitely excited to try
this out I think it's really incredible
what they're doing they're pushing the
industry forward with this new platform
at a new format and I'm so excited for
you guys to experience it because being
here in person and actually getting to
hear it like I wish that I could let you
hear it I just want take the headphones
off and put them on you well thank you
guys so much for watching I'm looking
forward to checking this out when it's
released it'll be out in the fall on iOS
and Android one of the things that I'm
really excited about is the live concert
aspect because this is really something
that is made for that immersive dynamic
experience taking live concerts like you
can't actually be there they can record
these and now using this 360 reality
audio it'll actually make it feel like
you're at the concert if you can't be
there well I'm gonna go that hop on a
plane to LAX what's that song violet
cardigan
[Music]
you